HAVE TO PLAY 26, 28 MINUTES ALL
WAITS.
AND A CENTRING PASS AND IT'S
WIDE..
NIETO.
AND HUTCHINSON MAKES THE SAVE.AN
LAST YEAR.
THEY WERE VERY GOOD IN MONTREALE
EVERY GAME STARTS AT
BET99.N A SHARP ANGLE
SHOT.
REBOUND.
COUTURE SCORES! THE GOAL CREASE,
SPEZZA GETS CAUGHT STANDING
ALONG SIDE..
BURNS STILL OUT THERE.
LOOSE IN FRONT.
GRAB THE PUCK ON TO THAT CURVE
.
SELVES TIED WITH WILLIAM
NYLANDER WITH 18 SH PASS ROLLS .
HILL GETS IT
TOMAS HERTL BACK THROUGH CENT K.
ONDREJ KASE ON THE BREAK.
Y KASE.
THE PUCK GOESE.
UP THE LINE BY MIDDLETON.
AND THEN, OH, IT'S GIVEN AWAY IT
PUCK WAS PLAYED WITH A
HIIE.
T.J. BRODIE TO SIMMONDS.
DROPS IT BACK TO RIELLY..
TIMO MEIER DROPS IT BACK.
QUICK CHANCE FOR DAHLEN KNOCKED.
THE SHARKS STAY WITH THIS PUCK.
MEHE FACT
IS THEY'RE GETTING BETTEE
THAT'S BLOCKED BY BALCERS.
TAVARES CENTRES IT.
NYLANDER TO OFF
ANGLE CENTRE ICE.
CHANCE AT THE EMPTY NET FOR
M.
SO THE LEAFS, WE TALKED ABOUT AT
THE TOP O O
MARNER LOOKING FOR THE PUCK IN
DOMINATING WIN